uh here's an interesting question that
came in via voicemail
yesterday i interviewed jessie lee
peterson on the program
and a lot of people had some version of
this question take a listen to it
hey david joel in florida i watched your
interview with jessie lee peterson i
wrote
the eclipse where he interviewed you in
the past i've watched some of the clips
of his show
i've looked online
my question is is this guy for real is
this sort of like a phil hendry where
he's playing a character or
a comedy routine or is this for real i'm
just wondering
what you think about that yeah so a lot
of people have asked me this
i do not believe jesse lee peterson is
playing a character and the reason i
don't believe that
is when i went to his uh studio in los
angeles
he was exactly the same off air now
maybe he's playing
and i'm talking like he's talking about
trump stuff and saying all the same
things
maybe it's such a commitment to the
character that he even continues off
air but i don't think jesse lee peterson
is playing a character which makes it
all the more scary
we've got a great bonus show for you
today one in five recent coronavirus
cases are people in their 20s
people in their 20s we will talk about
the new republican focus on joe biden's
son hunter and we will also talk about
what michael bloomberg did
to enable 32 000 additional floridians
to vote in november
very interesting and important stories
on the bonus show
get instant access instant by becoming a
member
at joinpacman.com